hey there sorry to bother you folks but
we're looking for an IND individual
golden brown complexion 15 lb no head I
know where he is I'll even serve him up
on a silver platter for you now get in
here glad to see you finally out of your
man cave well you know Amanda can be
pretty convincing when she wants to be
hey babe Eric's here hey Amanda well
well well well you made it yeah sorry
Thomas one second I baked this for you I
couldn't eat it by myself it' just be
too depressing why wow you bake this
yeah you know for a single guy I know my
way around the oven a guy in a uniform
who knows how to bake have a feeling
you're not going to be single for long
come on you remember my mom right hey
Mom remember ER Happy
Thanksgiving jeans and a sweater could
at least make an
effort casuals more my thing Cathleen
especially in my own house don't you
mean our house now you See's got to be a
little big hey hey hey Happy
Thanksgiving oh thank God you're back
Thomas thought we'd be eating a frozen
turkey
dinner sorry Rob yeah this is the first
time the store is open on Thanksgiving
you know we always do the uh midnight
Black Friday but people were showing up
at 6 p.m. anyway so and you're a smart
man Thomas yeah we'll credit my
beautiful fiance over there it was her
idea well from what I've been hearing
about the turnout it is going to be a
very Happy
Thanksgiving here we go wow that's
beautiful yes Mitch we need your carbing
skills I've got time to carve it but not
to eat it Thomas is not making you work
blame Bob apparently he's awall Thomas
called and said it's me working or fired
sorry buddy oh the store shouldn't even
be open it's Thanksgiving I know Mary
but let's face it like Friday starts on
a Thursday now even in
[Applause]
Plymouth hey Bon Jo let get the back of
the
[__] M we were here first everybody just
calm down two hits I hit you you the
ground Ki what Jesus everybody be
patient be a patient Mass General what
is WR the store opens in 10 minutes
you'll get your waffle iron ZX no you
got a fire
hose I need you at the
register
thank
[Music]
you you
more Kathleen sold my dad this house I
didn't realize she was coming with it
she'll never be able to replace her mom
just
yeah
and look at it this way so it was a
quick engagement so hopefully it' be a
quick
divorce please
call oh let's go Dad we're going to the
movies have fun Bobby I want to hear
about that 19 strikeout game against UCL
when you get back deal Thomas good night
everyone scuba invited Julia he's indoor
God it I'll gas him up
okay Bobby Bobby Bob arm P for
Thanksgiving and my rid what up dog I
heard you do Friday night guy I better
be with a 96 mile fast ball that's what
I'm
talking Evan you are such a what yo nice
job beating Handover SCBA I heard you
Unstoppable thanks man it was a pretty
good night until Tyson Fury over here
almost got us locked
upic what happened we got in a run in
with some drunk Handover I popped one of
them in the eye but this one was too
busy filming herself to get some footage
it would have broke the internet you are
lucky I didn't film that okay it was
like Waffle House level cringe it
[Music]
[Applause]
was this traffic is ridiculous oh I
can't hand
yo pit stop I need a new phone mine got
smashed in the fight we're not going to
the store it's Zoo yes we are cuz Evan
owes me a new Li don't worry don't worry
I'll buy guys I thought we were going to
the movie we are how am I going to text
her in the movie without a phone who are
you
texting oh yeah we need to do this quick
okay 5 minutes in now stealth Mission I
promise park your car here it's not a
car it's an SUV hey babe can I just stay
here please please don't make me do this
alone can I got a selfie hey one second
hey
man Bobby Bobby we have to move yeah
yeah one second one second Bobby goldar
alltime record holder for strikeouts at
pth East yes sir and started for the
I'll take Jess this is like the last
place I thought I'd see you yeah you and
me both your dad's store is insane right
now look at all these
people I'm sorry Ryan I I have to catch
up with my friends I you come on let's
go let's go so uh what are you doing
Saturday night going in cap with Bobby
all right well uh excuse me I'm having a
little get together with my friends
excuse me and uh you know if you wanted
to come by it's just going to be like a
couple people I can't Bob's only in time
till Monday so you should just swing by
early we could like play some drinking
games have a good time you know I got
some KS she's all set Ryan come on let's
go
[Applause]
EXC chill out he's just helping oh what
a
gentleman face it as long as golden arms
around your toast Scott burnt Scott
toast shut the Soggy toast I love you
dude but I'm kill you try your best open
that gate for man get in
here oh my God Jesus
Christ
this is insane yeah let's go in the back
[Applause]
okay
hey hey yo we got some unfinished
business oh that's the guy from Handover
I punch yo suck
[Applause]
my where's your mom
at cin cousin just get what you need and
get out of here in and out I
promise
hey why let those offs in there
hello ancient American holiday come on
man it's a pizza oven where do you think
it goes sorry [__] 10 minutes people
please come on hi surprise hey hey babe
what are you doing here I came in with
Eric I didn't want you to starve on
Thanksgiving I got a call on the radio
about needing some crowd control uh yeah
in fact you should probably Wai in here
okay okay are you okay yeah would you
yeah be
[Music]
careful guy Lonnie's 30 years old he got
held back 2 years he's dating a che J
does your dad still sell shot colors or
a tranquilizer or sedative this is like
in Apocalypse movies you can take
anything you want Evan scuba come on you
know what time it is boys let's go
Fletcher God here we go what happened to
steal Mission come on the store will
open in 10 minutes CP just stay calm
take a breath everybody's going to get
their FES all
right everybody just stay calm
please everybody just step back lock it
up now guys please nobody
I'm lock
the
St
first hold it hey hey open everyone we
need back up
immediately but don't get your off
[Applause]
liing dy I need
help oh my god dude this
happening
MD where the you
going open the door they're going to get
crushed open it you have to open the
door you have to get the
MCH